I see you a lot in magazines taking
these in these beautiful photo shoots
which obviously it's it's it's part of
your job as part of what you do but
you're you're in these beautiful glossy
magazines and then there was I wanted to
this is w magazine I think and I saw
this photo recently and I don't know
what's going on in this scenario it's
you in a very sexy outfit and you're
marching with NF it's the Nutcracker or
that is the Nutcracker there's this one
and then there's the follow up to where
it's getting really creepy where he's
like and it's very artistic I really
love it but I don't know do they do they
tell you these ideas before they spring
them on you or you sure told me they
told me that they would take me to Rose
Garden to a Rose Garden and that's all
they told you yep and then this and then
this guy walks in and then this young
handsome guy walks in and he's not in
the outfit yet and I'm like oh I don't
know what he's doing here and then I see
the outfit on like wow and I see latex
latex lots of latex and I mean thank God
it was W Magazine and I was not like
trapped in Lane it wasn't like a set of
masochists I've checked those magazines
and you were not in them I've checked
them thoroughly yes still have not shown
up you know I want to ask you briefly
because I want to talk about the film
which I really loved and and I saw last
night but I first wanted to ask you
about you grew up and I think I can tell
this about you just by talking to you
grew up in a very creative home is this
right your father was a mine my father
was a mine and a director on stage my
mother is and I mean my father is still
a director and matter my mother to an
actress and you didn't watch what was
interesting
they didn't you didn't watch TV as
children they let you just know yeah I
think the first time I watched TV at
home when they bought a TV I was seven
right so I would go to the neighbors to
watch TV but I was not very interesting
I'm
still not very interesting you're
watching TV oh that yeah okay
it's the highest of all the art forms
now you don't have TV but what I
actually I believe this is important
because I don't think kids should watch
a lot of TV
and I think it can stunt creativity if
they especially at a young age if
they're watching it too much what kinds
of things would you do to be creative oh
well anything but the walls in our
apartment were our territories so we
would draw right everywhere in the
apartment and your parents would allow
that they would let yeah they told us
well this is your space and they started
to get a little nervous when we grew up
and we started to do mixtures with gum
and tooth passed and anything yeah gum
and tooth paste they're not cool with
that they thought you were going to be
doing like really cool paintings and
stuff just ugly
yeah and sticky and sticky and you're
like oh it's my peanut butter expression
you can yeah but they which they
wouldn't say any good for them I think
that's very important and I bet it's
made it's made you a creative person or
helps you develop your creativity yeah
absolutely